[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Bene misión
especial de Europa y el programa de
actualidad Europea de France 24 en
español yo soy Esther Herrera caro desde
los estudios de París de France 24 donde
entrevistamos a José Manuel Álvarez
ministro español de asuntos exteriores
Unión Europea y cooperación en un
momento clave cuando España en menos de
un mes tomará la presidencia rotatoria
del Consejo de la Unión Europea la
institución que representa a los Estados
miembros y justo cuando se acaban de
convocar elecciones generales en España
el próximo 23 de Julio bienvenido Miss
instrau Gracias Muchísimas gracias por
estar aquí en France 24 ministro en
menos de un mes España estrena la
presencia rotatoria del Consejo se han
convocado elecciones anticipadas se van
a celebrar el próximo 23 de julio y la
pregunta Inevitable es le preocupa que
la presencia española que de alguna
forma deslucida en absoluto no me
preocupa en absoluto ha habido
presidencias de todo tipo y de todo
color la última presidencia francesa
tuvo precisamente las elecciones
presidenciales con porque sea dos
vueltas y las elecciones legislativas
durante la presidencia con un cambio de
gobierno ha habido presidencias con
gobiernos en funciones ha habido
presidencias con cambio de gobierno por
mociones de censura va a ser un éxito lo
único que me preocupa es que el gobierno
de España puede llegar a una coalición
de derecha radicalizada y de extrema
derecha con propuestas claramente lo
dicen abiertamente contrarias contrarias
a la agenda 2030 contrarias al pacto
verde contrarias a la igualdad entre
hombres y mujeres eso es lo único que me
preocupa pero la presidencia pilotada
por el gobierno de España va a ser un
éxito justamente
teme entonces que no se pueda revalidar
este gobierno progresista que hay ahora
mismo en España son los españoles los
que van a tener lo que decidir el
presidente ha convocado unas elecciones
de manera muy democrática buscando una
clarificación para el día 23 de julio y
desde luego la fuerza política que
representa el partido socialista lo que
plantea es que no se pare el crecimiento
económico yo Esta semana he estado aquí
en una reunión Ministerial de la ocd en
el que se han presentado económicas para
España por este organismo internacional
independiente hablamos de un crecimiento
económico previsto el doble que la Unión
Europea una de las infracciones más
bajas de la zona Euro eso no se puede
parar y tampoco la protección social
Frente a las consecuencias económicas y
sociales de la agresión brutal e injusta
de Rusia Ucrania la defensa de la
sanidad pública la defensa de la
educación pública el incremento del
salario mínimo interprofenal de las
pensiones todo eso no puede parar
entre sus prioridades en la presidencia
Aunque el presidente Pedro Sánchez tuvo
que retrasar su discurso en el
parlamento europeo hasta septiembre la
presidencia tiene en su calendario una
fecha clave que es el 17 y 18 de julio
que será la Cumbre bajo la presidencia
española con los países de la celac que
resultados debería tener esta Cumbre
para considerar que sea una reunión de
éxito esta Cumbre es un hito y yo estoy
seguro que iba a ser un éxito no se
celebra desde el año 2015 Europa es muy
en estos momentos tan complejos y tan
convulsos en el mundo que necesitamos
amigos y aliados y América Latina
comparte nuestros valores cree en el
multilateralismo rechaza la guerra como
forma de resolver conflictos en entre
Estados cree la democracia el éxito
vendrá del impulso político y ese lo
vamos a conseguir en la Cumbre los días
17 y 18 de julio 60 jefes de estado y de
gobierno lo que eso representa a nivel
de población mundial de pib de fuerza
política en segundo lugar tiene que
haber un programa potente de inversiones
con América Latina de financiación a
América Latina para garantizar que más
allá de la presidencia española América
Latina que es nuestro deseo el deseo del
gobierno de España siga en el centro en
el corazón de la Unión Europea y
finalmente tenemos que impulsar los
acuerdos comerciales con chile con
México el de mercosur porque para
América Latina no son solo acuerdos
comerciales son también una de
compromiso político a largo plazo de
Europa precisamente ahora hablaremos
sobre el acuerdo de mercosur peralte
Pero antes Permíteme hacerme una
pregunta el presidente brasileño Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva ha presentado
cierto plan para impulsar la paz en la
guerra en Ucrania que le parece no sé si
ha tenido de alguna oportunidad en algún
contacto con el gobierno brasileño al
respecto hablo por supuesto cada vez que
veo a mi colega brasileño sobre la
situación en Ucrania entre otros temas
yo creo que es muy positivo que todos
los países del Mundo hablen de paz de
paz en Ucrania lo que es importante es
que todos demos el mismo contenido a la
palabra Paz para el gobierno de España
la situación es muy clara la paz tiene
que ser una paz dentro de la carta de
las Naciones Unidas una paz que
garantice la soberanía y la integridad
territorial de Ucrania dentro de sus
fronteras internacionalmente reconocidas
usted ha hecho referencia al acuerdo
entre la Unión Europea y mercosur un
pacto que se cerró en 2019 después de 20
años de idas y venidas pero aún se están
esperando una serie de contrapropuestas
por parte del bloque de mercosur Hay
posibilidades de que salga adelante este
pacto Desde luego por España no va a
quedar y nosotros desde luego lo que
queremos es que haya un avance es un
pacto muy complejo estamos hablando de
que el acuerdo entre la Unión Europea y
mercosur incumbe muchos países de ver
muchas ratificaciones pero desde luego
el gobierno de España y la presidencia
española de la Unión Europea van a
ponerlo todo para hacerlo avanzar cree
que hay voluntad política y reticencias
por algunos países Francia Austria
Irlanda y por parte de mercosur Brasil
yo lo que le diría a todos los países
que conforman mercosur Y la Unión
Europea lo que les digo en torno a la
mesa en Bruselas a mis colegas y amigos
europeos es que estos Son acuerdos y en
concreto que beneficia mutuamente a
ambas regiones y que la mejor forma de
garantizar que América Latina esté en
los acuerdos de París de lucha contra el
cambio climático es de que tengamos un
diálogo político sobre todos los temas
Es que este acuerdo sea ratificado y
otro en vigor hemos hecho mención a la
guerra en Ucrania otra cuestión que
también marca las relaciones exteriores
y ha transcurrido prácticamente un año y
medio desde la invasión nota fatiga a la
hora de sancionar a Vladimir Putin y al
régimen en absoluto llevamos 10 paquetes
de sanciones y siempre que nos reunimos
los ministros de asuntos exteriores una
de las cosas de las que hablamos es de
analizar si puede haber nuevas sanciones
para debilitar el esfuerzo de guerra de
Vladimir Putin es el único objetivo que
la guerra termine que vuelva la paz a
Ucrania y al mismo tiempo también si
podemos mejorar la eficacia de las
sanciones para asegurarnos que nadie la
salude falta se está negociando mismo el
paquete número 11 de sanciones cree que
el reciente ataque en la presa de novaka
puede tener consecuencias más allá Yo
creo que lo que demuestra ese ataque es
que hay violaciones en estos momentos
muy claras muy flagrantes del derecho
internacional humanitario hasta la
guerra tiene leyes y están siendo
violadas y aquellos responsables de esos
crímenes de guerra que se están
cometiendo en suelo ucraniano tendrán
que responder ante la justicia
internacional considera que es un crimen
de guerra
hay una investigación en marcha y no
seré yo quien lo diga lo que sí está muy
claro es que la destrucción de
infraestructuras civiles está tipificado
como crimen de guerra es contrario al
derecho internacional humanitario y Es
evidente que desde el inicio de la
guerra en Ucrania se están cometiendo
crímenes de guerra es por supuesto a los
jueces y a los investigadores España
apoya al fiscal general de la Corte
Penal Internacional hay un equipo de la
policía científica española ayudando a
la fiscalía ucraniana a recabar pruebas
Son ellos los que tendrán que dictaminar
exactamente la tipificación jurídica
Próximamente los líderes europeos
tendrán que empezar a discutir se abren
o no negociaciones con Ucrania para
entrar en un futuro como país en miembro
veo Ucrania como futuro socio por
supuesto España apoyó el estatuto de
candidato de la Unión Europea sobre eso
no hay ninguna duda
como comentábamos antes ahora mismo se
están negociando el undécimo paquete de
sanciones pero lo que ocurre en política
exterior es que muchas decisiones se
toman por unanimidad España junto a
otros países ha mostrado su intención de
acabar con la nulidad con ciertas
cuestiones así agilizar las decisiones
cuando cree que podría llevarse a cabo
cree que hay espíritu para poderlo
conseguir España es parte del grupo de
amigos de la mayoría cualificada si algo
ha demostrado la crisis del covid 19 y
la agresión ilegal de Rusia Ucrania es
que Europa actúa bien cuando actúa
rápido cercano al ciudadano con agilidad
y flexibilidad Y eso supone pasar de la
unanimidad en ocasiones a la mayoría
cualificada en distintos aspectos pero
claramente en la política exterior y de
seguridad nuestra presidencia de la
Unión Europea lo va a impulsar
en los últimos días hemos visto cada vez
más incursiones de supuestos grupos
prorusos contrarios al kremlin que
entran en el territorio ruso atentan en
él hemos visto algunas imágenes
preocupantes en una investigación podría
ser se podría estar utilizando armamento
de países de la otan le preocupan estas
incursiones que se puede utilizar
munición no tengo constancia de eso he
leído en la prensa pero no tengo
constancia de eso todo el material que
España entrega y que la Unión Europea
entrega tiene un único objetivo la
defensa de la soberanía la integridad
territorial y los civiles indefensos
ucranianos y que la paz regrese a
Ucrania de una vez lo antes posible
ningún otro ningún otro objetivo pero le
preocupa que puedan utilizar munición de
los aliados si fuera el caso insisto no
me gusta hacer política ficción las
relaciones internacionales se basan en
hechos no en especulaciones
por último las relaciones con china más
aún durante la Guerra en Ucrania son muy
importantes usted viajó recientemente a
China con el presidente del gobierno
español Pedro Sánchez Por una parte la
Unión Europea ha pedido que se implique
que utilice su influencia sobre Rusia
para poner fin a la invasión pero a la
vez esto implica también dar de alguna
forma más peso geopolítico a China cómo
se puede conjugar este equilibrio china
es una gran potencia desde un punto de
vista de población militar económico
necesitamos a China para cosas tan
existenciales como la lucha contra la
emergencia climática Y sí cuando
estuvimos en Pekín desde luego la
conversación se le pidió al presidente
sí que ayude que ponga todo ese
ascendente y toda esa influencia que
pueda tener sobre Rusia y Vladimir Putin
para que la paz regrese a Ucrania y cuál
fue la sensación que tuvo después de ese
viaje Permítame que la reserva
diplomática
me haga reservarme detalles sobre ese
respecto lo que sí le puedo decir es que
España en su diálogo con China y con
todos los países del mundo siempre habla
en favor de la paz en Ucrania y de una
paz dentro de los principios de la carta
de las Naciones Unidas Muchísimas
gracias ministro no tenemos tiempo para
más les agradezco muchísimo su tiempo a
ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de Europa hoy Gracias por ver
France 24 en español
[Música]